what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday was
a pretty crazy day with the announcement
that scarlett johansson was suing disney
over black widow
and if you don't know what i'm talking
about you don't know what the lawsuit is
don't worry i'll explain it but today
more importantly kevin feige the
president of marvel studios
has reportedly expressed how he feels
about this current situation
so keep in mind scarlett johansson is
specifically suing
disney not marvel studios yes disney
does own marvel studios but they are
still
different entities and apparently it
does seem like scarlett
and kevin feige are good but kevin
doesn't exactly feel good about the
entire situation so if you're a little
bit confused about the situation or
you haven't heard it don't worry let me
explain it all very simplistically
and keep in mind this is all that we
know this is what the public
knows we don't know every single little
detail about scarlett johansson's
contract we just know what the official
statement
from the lawsuit actually says and
here's the most simplistic way to say
this
the money that scarlett johansson was
supposed to get paid for black widow was
largely based off of box office
performance
meaning the better the movie did in the
theaters and the more money it made
the more money scarlett johansson would
make and according to the lawsuit that
she
filed when disney decided to release
black widow on disney plus
and in theaters at the same time they
violated her contract the official
statement reads
disney intentionally induced marvel's
breach of the agreement without
justification
in order to prevent miss johansen from
realizing the full benefit
of her bargain with marvel another
official a statement
from the lawsuit says to maximize these
receipts and thereby protect her
financial interest ms johansen extracted
a promise from marvel
that the release of the picture would be
a theatrical release
and a theatrical release means an
exclusive theatrical release so the
lawsuit from scarlett johansson states
that
disney violated her contract by
releasing black widow in theaters
and on disney plus as premier access at
the same time
now disney did release their official
statement about the situation yesterday
as well
and this is what disney's official
statement reads there is no merit
whatsoever to this filing
the lawsuit is especially sad and
distressing in its callous disregard for
the horrific
and prolonged global effects of the
coven 19 pandemic
disney has fully complied with miss
johansen's contract and furthermore the
release of black widow on disney plus
with premier access has significantly
enhanced her ability to earn additional
compensation
on top of the 20 million she has
received to date so in other words
disney says
no we didn't breach her contract in fact
we've worked with her and she can make
money off of disney plus
but clearly this wasn't enough for
scarlett because she filed the lawsuit
but here's where kevin feige comes in
and where we have a report about how he
feels about this entire thing
because you have to remember kevin feige
is the president of marvel studios and
the chief creative officer over
marvel in general not with disney and
according to
the hollywood reporters newsletter this
is how kevin
feige feels about the situation the
report from the hollywood reporter reads
as follows
kevin feige is a company man and not
prone to corporate showdowns or shouting
matches
but i'm told he's angry and embarrassed
he lobbied disney against the
day-and-date plan for black widow
preferring the big screen exclusivity
and not wanting to upset his talent
and then when the crap started to hit
the fan the movie started tanking and
johansen's team threatened litigation
kevin foggy wanted disney to make this
right with her and they apparently
reached out to disney to comment on this
but they declined the comment so that's
how kevin feige feels about the
situation and i think
a lot of people would probably prefer to
do this on the back end to negotiate
things
out of the public's view so nobody
really finds out about it so kevin feige
is apparently angry
and embarrassed but hopefully disney and
scarlet can work this out they've had a
great run together for many
many years a lot of people really really
love black widow and really really love
marvel and disney so hopefully they can
all work it out
and all will be well but in the meantime
let me know what you think about this
situation let me know what you think
about what kevin feige feels about the
situation and of course to stay up to
date on all things happening in the mcu
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell don't forget to like
this video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you